professional racer and Mythbusters star
Jessi combs died on Tuesday at the age
of 36 ET can confirm the Harney County
Sheriff's Office confirmed to ET that
they received a call around 4:00 p.m. on
Tuesday reporting that a jet car
attempting to break a land speed record
crashed in the Albert desert in Oregon
deputies arrived on the scene and
identified the driver and sole fatality
in the vehicle as Combs who was
pronounced dead at the scene the cause
of the crash is still unknown terry
madden a member of Combs's team
confirmed her death in an Instagram post
on Wednesday sharing this video of he
and combs who was known as the fastest
woman on four wheels this little wire
right here this is the go baby girl wire
madden caption the post quote i have
never loved or been loved by anyone as
much as this amazing woman she was truly
my unicorn and I enjoyed every single
minute that I had with her she was the
most amazing spirit that I have ever or
will ever know madden revealed that he
was the first one on the scene when
combs died and noted that they quote did
everything humanly possible to save her
prior to Mythbusters combs was a co-host
on the Spike TV series Xtreme 4x4 for
five years nothing's gonna happen until
you push your go button she replaced
kari byron who was on maternity leave
for the seventh season of Mythbusters in
2009 appearing in 12 episodes total
[Music]